[Music]
in an ideal world you look back at
picture with your prom and love your
dress but that's not the case for
everybody particularly these girls take
a look at pimp wrong dress these girls
regretted wearing and hit the red button
down below to subscribe to our channel
pink fairy if there's one thing the
girls on my Big Fat Gypsy Wedding know
about its extravagant dresses and their
elaborate capes aren't just restricted
to Royal gowns either they go all out
for proms two huge pink dresses like
Glinda the Good Witch tour and The
Wizard of Oz are one of the most popular
styles Carolee anyone wearing a big
Moraine dress like this is going to
regret it possibly even before the night
is over given how uncomfortable and
impractical it must be that cheap prom
dresses are supposed to be crossing
teams like this girl didn't get that
memo perhaps she had a disaster when
their actual dress the last minute and
ended up having to improvise with a
bedsheet and a pair of scissors what
else could explain this dress it's even
too skimpy to be worn to a toga party
we're pretty sure she would have ended
up slashing some temptation and surely
we would have lived to regret that how
do we body prom dresses and bright
colors can grab attention for all the
right reasons but this outfit was
iooking for all the wrong reasons the
garnish colors are one issue and the
spots are another the Botes on this
dress almost looks like a colorful snake
the fact that this couples outfits are
probably made out of duct tape
for the annual duct tape scholarship
contest doesn't excuse the crazy
patterns
let's hope they won otherwise they might
well have regretted their choice
star wars we get it you really love Star
Wars but one day you probably won't and
you might well look back at your prom
photos and regret dressing up as Padme
you have to give this girl props though
for her commitment to the theme that
headdress doesn't look this is really
comfortable and props to her date we
dressed up too he looks pretty happy to
be holding that lightsaber ruffles and
bows less is more
a lot of people who wear regrettable
prom dresses would have benefited from
following that idea sometimes a simple
classic gown is the most suitable choice
for a formal event like a prom you
isn't so suitable a bright yellow outfit
complete with a boat across the chest
and a lot of spin on show with gray
ruffles cascading down the sides
oh why read all about it most girls
dream of their prom dresses being so
fabulous
they'll make front-page news this girl's
took that into her own hands by wearing
actual newspaper pages and her date
accessorized to suit for the newspaper
bow tie and a handkerchief in his top
pocket she shown some pretty impressive
skills with the preening of the pages
and the shape of the Botes but surely
she looks back at these pictures and
years to come and wished she hadn't gone
down the DIY route criss-cross matching
outfits are often regrettable and when
you throw bizarre material into the mix
you've got a recipe for major regrets
those Criss crosses all over her legs
must have made it difficult to dance or
even walk the matching bag just takes it
to the next level and don't even get us
started on the pattern surely this
couple will look back at photographs of
their prom outfits in years to come and
wonder what they were thinking team
spirit it's easy to get caught up in the
world of high school like rooting for
your school sports team but it's
probably best to leave your two spirit
courtside rather than bring it to prom
you're dating a basketball star so what
that doesn't mean a sport helps to
inspire your prom dress it probably
seems like a genius idea at the time
we're pretty sure girls who wear
basketball teams prom dresses live to
regret their decisions camo catastrophe
a surprising number of girls wear
camouflage dresses to prom and it's such
a strange choice why would anyone feel
the need to wear something that could
blend in with trees leaves and bushes
but what makes the camo look even weird
is when it's coupled with a more
traditional style like this bizarre camo
and baby pink combination if this dress
were just pink it wouldn't be so
regrettable but add in that camouflaged
layer and surely shall look back in
horror sell it out it's a general rule
that your prom dress shouldn't have
anything written on it there's really no
need
knows who you are and that's all that
matters another rule of thumb is to try
to keep things classy so wearing a prom
dress with the word wrap girl emblazoned
across the backside isn't really the
best move at least it wouldn't have
shown up in a social photos unless she
deliberately turned her back to the
camera boy will she have a Greta gasps
which of these prom dresses is the most
regrettable tell us in the comments and
give us a big thumbs up
[Music]
you